women that are getting work done if you
pulled their husbands what percent of
them would say yes I am so happy my wife
is putting in injections into her face
the mother of my children yes I am so
happy that the mother of my children is
tattooing eyeliner yes I am so excited
that the mother of my children spends 2
hours every day on her makeup do men
really want this and the common argument
that I hear is yes men want it but they
don't know that they want it and what
that tells me is I get more attention
from men when I do these things and my
question is if you're married why do you
need attention and validation from the
outside world why is your husband's
opinion not the most important and
really if you want to belong to a guy
question is what does he like when I
wear it what does he want me to do and
most men look at all of this stuff as an
expense